Hello Snips
Master?
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
This will be my Full Ahsoka Episode 4 video.
There were so many Star Wars Easter Eggs
and references, paying off a bunch of long
running fan theories, too.
Probably one of the best episodes
of the season so far.
So we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes in cable for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet,
because there were
a lot of really big payoffs
that they had in this episode.
We'll start at the beginning
of the episode, work
our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments,
but the episode title was Fallen Jedi,
which is a reference to both
and again Skywalker, because obviously
he appears during the episode.
Not a dry eye in the house
at the end of that episode either.
and I came.
The title is also meant to be a reference
to Baylan Skoll because both of that
like Baylan Skoll is also a fallen
Jedi like India and Skywalker,
who turn to the dark side and again
became a Sith became Darth Vader.
But Baylan Skoll, even though they turn
to the dark side, did not become Seth.
That's why is lightsabers orange
and not full Sith red.
they haven't completely answered
that question.
But we're only halfway through the series
and like we just tease
the world between worlds and again
Skywalker appearing in he's not a force
goes like
this is not for us goes and again
this is a real version of an act
like he's appearing to her and he's alive.
we're going to answer
every single question at episode four.
most of the fight though, that he has
with Ahsoka, he taunts her with the memory
of an can Skywalker Order 66 and Darth
Vader Everyone in the order knew.
And I can. Skywalker.
You would live to see what he became.
I know there'll be a lot of questions
about what this grand plan he has like
what is this better future
that he's trying to use Thrawn for?
Like, even though he says
that the war is inevitable
and all this collateral damage is bad,
but it's necessary for a better future.
A lot of people wondering
what is that better future
don't worry, we'll get into that
during that part of the episode.
the actual opening scene starts
a little bit different, barely
with any sound like
it's almost a completely silent scene
inside the ship
with the sounds of the electrical systems
and Hu Yang trying to fix their comms.
they're trying to get Hera on the comm.
Obviously,
they eventually do wind up getting her
who Yang tries to rewire the ship.
She references Fulcrum again. Home one.
Remember Home.
One is just the name
of the New Republic Fleet ship,
which is a mon calamari capital ship,
the same one from the original trilogy.
Like, that's the same briefing room
that we saw during Return of the Jedi
Fulcrum was a serious position
inside the rebellion,
going back
to before the original trilogy started.
Like she served
as the point of communication
between the rebel cells, the fulcrum
between all the different rebel cells
said that
the whole running plotline was Sabine
not being able to destroy the map
when Ahsoka tells her, look like we might
not actually be able to save Ezra,
are you prepared to destroy the map
to prevent Thrawn from coming back in
this entire war against the New Republic?
We don't want to have another Star War.
pretty easy to assume
that she was going to go left.
Like not going to be able
to destroy the map.
I think they were trying to tease that
in earlier episodes
where she also did not listen to Ahsoka
and took off with the map
to try and discover
what was really going on.
she also drops a very big Easter egg
for that
original Thrawn trilogy of books,
Heir to the Empire, Better that.
And allowing
Thorne's return as heir to the Empire.
He said it.
He said.
Baylan Skoll
Then, since Shin Hati
to stop Ahsoka in Sabine from stopping
their process of finishing the hyperspace
ring and jumping to the other galaxy,
He's not necessarily worried
about killing Ahsoka and Sabine,
only delaying them long enough
to get their hyperspace coordinates
and complete their mission.
That's why at the end,
he doesn't want to kill Sabine.
He tries to turn her to the dark side.
the kind of references in the last episode
where he said
he was regretful at the idea
that he might have to kill a soldier
like there are so few Jedi out there.
Do we really need to kill them all
that's because he would rather turn them
if they can be turned.
But he's not afraid to kill them
if he needs to.
But that's why Balan says that he's
not afraid of what will happen to Morgan.
Because you kind of toss them like,
are you afraid of a
so going to be like, No, he's not afraid.
He's just cautious
because he knows about Ahsoka's skills.
As a former Jedi.
when it's Luke is giving Sabine
that talk about making the harder choices.
You notice that they frame the shots
that you can see her.
HOLDREN That has the space wheel on it,
which is meant to be a reference
to her finding.
Ezra Bridger Because the space wells
are so critical to this,
when she talks about doing what's right
regardless of personal feelings.
This is also a really big teaser
for what happens later
with her going to the world between worlds
and seeing Enoch and Skywalker
in the flesh again.
the line is meant to reference
a couple of different things.
Her whole reason for leaving the Jedi
order, like trying to do the right thing,
even if it goes against
her personal feelings
because she did want to stay
with the Incan Skywalker
but felt like it was the wrong thing
to do.
Staying in the Jedi Order.
but the other foreshadowing
here is the idea
that she could use the power of the world
between worlds to literally pull
in a can Skywalker through time,
completely changing the paths
so that he never becomes
Darth Vader in never joined the Empire
and he's still alive in present day.
I can stop Cain from dying.
You can't save your master.
And I can't save my.
talking about Jedi time travel.
The World between Worlds was a theory
that a lot of us had
when they first started dropping these
so controllers in.
They were showing the map here.
Now, they hadn't explained
exactly what was going on with the map,
but all the lines behind them
in the trailer here,
when they were fighting each other,
looked like the same markings
that you see inside
the world between worlds.
A lot of people were like, wait a minute,
are they inside the world between rules in
obviously they weren't in this scene,
but it looks like something was happening.
Like some force energy was in play
that opened a gate to the world
between worlds.
And that's how a soldier was pulled in
when she fell off the cliff.
The whole idea, though, is that Ahsoka is
going to have to make the hard choice
and not pull Anika and Skywalker
through time to avoid the whole Darth
Vader of it all.
just like she wanted Sabine
to destroy the map to prevent Theron's
chances from coming back.
Mostly because changing the past
that much by literally pulling in again.
Skywalker through time,
could cause something even worse
to happen in present day
because he might have never killed
the emperor.
things with the emperor
might have gotten even worse,
especially with the second Death Star.
time travel mostly creates more problems
than it solves.
Like everybody saw either
the Flash TV series or the Flash movie.
Like pull out all the Flash memes.
sure is an ice time.
Be a shame if someone messed that up.
Just make it
the Star Wars edition of that.
Then we get the scene of Hu
Yang versus the HK droid.
He's got a little fight in him.
Like he's not totally helpless,
like C-3PO.
we get to see some of Sabine's
Mandalorian skills.
More practical fighting skills uses
a lot of the same weapons
and gear as the regular mandalorians
like Bo-Katan in Mando,
she's got her twin blasters from Star Wars
rebels, her grappling hook.
But this time they also show
you how both she and a soldier's abilities
work together, her, slicing the mercenary
in half with her light saber.
As Sabine
draws him in with the grappling hook,
that was about,
who Yang was talking about
when he said that they always do
better when they worked together,
When they stayed together,
going to be kind of hard
now that Sabine is on her way
to the other galaxy and Ahsoka is stuck
in this world between worlds
sort of outside of time and space,
they reference here again
and it was pretty predictable
what was going to happen
like they do get a hold of her
and she calls an audible
using Carson TiVo, who comes back in
another cameo scene
to take a squad of X-Wings to the planet,
making a very literal Star Wars rebels
reference once a rebel, always a rebel
This time they take the ghost ship,
the full ghost from Star Wars rebels.
The phantom
that she just used in the earlier
episode is docked on the rear
part of the ghost.
when they take off,
they also call her Phenix leader.
I think that's meant to be a reference
to Phenix cell from Star Wars
Rebels because all the Star Wars rebels
characters were part of Phenix Cell.
you also notice
that Jason is there with her
and she references him, eventually
becoming a general
in the New Republic fleet,
that would basically be during
the events of the sequel movies.
We'll see.
Like they haven't really explained
what happened with Jason
during that time period,
just because they didn't use
a lot of the animated characters
during the sequel movies.
there was a brief voiceover
from Ashley Dean's version of Ahsoka
during Rise of Skywalker,
but like, that's about as close as we got
when we see Balan arguing
with Morgan Elsbeth about their hyperspace
calculations and how hard it's going to be
to actually make the jump, he claims
they'll be lost to the void
if they're even a little bit off.
He's talking about the void
between galaxies because it's
basically a bunch of nothingness.
this is actually a real world thing.
Like space is full of a lot of emptiness,
like most of space is literally empty
the distance between galaxies,
though, is incredibly vast.
Like there's no planets, no asteroids,
no space, does nothing.
Have faith and faith.
I lost that a long time ago.
and when he says he lost faith
a long time ago, that's also a reference
to leaving the Jedi Order
and turning to the dark side after order
66, He lost faith in the Jedi Order
a long time ago.
They're trying to draw
a lot of parallels between Ahsoka
because she left the Jedi Order
and also Anakin Skywalker,
because he also kind of left
the Jedi order
when he fell to the dark side.
Morgan Elsbeth uses her Knights sister
force powers to activate the map again
in calculating hyperspace coordinates.
that's
what Bayley means when he says witchcraft.
He's talking about Knights
sister force abilities
because they're literally called force
witches
they have a bit of a funny moment
when Ahsoka and Sabine engage Marrok
and she's not in combat like they have
this right smiles between a couple of them
like she's very excited to fight Sabine
again in a soldier also smiling at Marrok
and that right away like, oh,
I'm going to have fun destroying you Early
on, they mostly focus on Ahsoka
versus Marrok and she's only
using one of her lightsabers this time
because she only needs one.
the whole idea is that she's well versed
in all forms of lightsaber combat,
so she's equally as deadly or as effective
with one lightsaber as she is with two.
The other thing going on here too,
like where she lifts the lightsaber
above her head and just holds it there.
That's also meant to be the same form
that Anna and Skywalker and Obi-Wan
used during the prequels like master,
like Padawan Dave Filoni just laying
more Anakin Skywalker prequel
references in here all along the way.
The whole thing with Mark's inquisitor
lightsaber spinning is also something
they use during rebels.
They also use it during the Obi-Wan Kenobi
series.
Do all inquisitor lightsabers can do that?
but here's the thing, though.
Instead of completely
answering all of our moral questions,
they almost raised more questions
because when she slices through him,
he just turns into dust.
So this is the important distinction.
He's not turning into a force ghost
because you see, Ash,
when you turn into force, goes
your body literally
just turns into nothingness.
Sit in other dark Jedi
also cannot become force ghosts either.
this is actually what's going on with him.
And you get to rewatch the scene
a couple of times
and you have to be watching it
on a pretty decent monitor
like have you watching a potato quality
version of the episode.
You might not see
what's actually happening.
when all the smoke starts billowing
out of him, there's a green tinge to it.
So I think the idea is that Morgan
Elsbeth used her nicest
her powers to resurrect
a force user into stuff him in this armor.
So Morocco may have actually been
a Sith inquisitor at one point,
but it's probably somebody who died
and they just resurrected using her
niceness sister powers because that's
a very common thing that they can do.
even if you didn't
watch all the Clone Wars episodes,
if you played Jedi Survivor or Jedi
Fallen Order, they kind of get into this
with Mirren's nice sister, Powers
resurrecting the dead, basically.
Now the question is who was Marrok like?
Was he a version of Darth
Maul who died at some point because Darth
Maul was born to a nice sister?
This woman here saying
or it could have been playing his voice
because saying,
where was the voice of Darth Maul?
So he did a lot of this kind of stuff,
nice sister adjacent type of stuff.
Let me know in the comments
if Marrok was resurrected using knights.
Mr. Powers,
who do you think he was before he died?
like is it
simply what you see is what you get like,
was he just Marrok before this?
He wasn't anybody special.
if you thought they were crazy
moronic theories
before this,
just wait till after this episode.
a lot of people had their starkiller
theories, their Ezra Bridger theories.
I feel like those are all invalid now.
Like he wasn't starkiller and he's not
a dark version of Ezra or a clone of Ezra.
Somehow they might answer some more
questions in the next couple of weeks.
We'll see about that
because there's still lots of questions
with the Baylan Skoll character
just in general.
you could see Dave Filoni
laughing at everybody and all their moral
theories behind the scenes.
Then we get our big Ahsoka
versus Balan school scene.
They've been teasing this in the trailers
for a long time.
So the whole idea is he's
waiting at the waypoint.
It actually looks a little bit different,
but the map is still active here,
So it's meant to be basically
the same thing
that was happening
when Morgan Elsbeth was still here.
But she went back to the ship.
That's why he's the only person
that's sitting here
And he also tries to throw the idea
in Ahsoka's face like really throw her off
by claiming that she's largely responsible
for everything like blaming
order 66 and Anna-Kat Skywalker
turning to Darth Vader on her leaving.
And again,
that's what he means when he claims Ahsoka
walked away in abandoned Anakin
and they actually kind of got into this
in some of the more expanded material to
The point
is that Ahsoka feels guilty about leaving.
And again, when she left the Jedi Order
in things like internally thinks that
had she not left him,
she could have actually been there
to help him
when he started to become afraid and see
the force visions about PADMÉ dying.
they've also got into this and a lot of
other Star Wars and Darth Vader material.
The idea is that Anna can felt so afraid.
That's why he was so willing to believe
what the emperor was telling him.
Oh, the Kool-Aid that the emperor
was pouring for him.
when really the emperor was just trying
to use an akin to get rid of the Jedi
in execute order 66.
Like he would have told anyone anything,
they might address this a little bit.
When Ahsoka talks to
and again in the world between worlds.
The other important detail here too,
is that it sounds like Balan school knew
that Anakin Skywalker became Darth
Vader the way that he talks about him.
And that was actually a pretty big secret
amongst the people in the Star Wars
universe.
Only a few people actually knew
that Anderson Skywalker was Darth Vader
in school claims to her
that he's trying to secure the future.
Something for her greater.
I know a lot of people wondering
what does that actually mean?
I think the whole idea is that
he has this grand vision for a new type
of Jedi order that's completely different
from the old Jedi order.
and he's basically trying to use Thrawn
to bring that about.
Like he feels like
he can't do that with Luke Skywalker
being around in the galaxy
with his Jedi Academy.
they haven't directly referenced
Luke Skywalker's Jedi Academy
or what Luke Skywalker is doing right now.
Yep, that might wind up happening
eventually.
I think because they want to focus more on
the Incan Skywalker
relationship with all this stuff
that's happening right now.
We'll see if Ahsoka winds up referencing,
talking to Luke Skywalker,
being with him at his Jedi
Academy recently when she talks to
and again in next week's
episode, Inside the World Between Worlds,
their fight,
though, plays out a little bit
more like Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker's
fight during Empire Strikes Back.
Like a much slower beginning with them
kind of carefully
circling around each other
just a little bit.
that's mostly
because they're both so powerful, like
the island school was meant
to be way more powerful than Morag
or anyone Ahsoka has faced before.
His lightsaber is also meant
to be way more hardcore,
like it's huge compared to hers.
Physically, he's also just way
bigger and way stronger than her.
He almost strikes her right off the clip
with his regular light saber strikes.
it's a little bit like the relationship
between Anarchy and Skywalker's
lightsaber
fighting style in Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Fighting style
like Obi-Wan Kenobi, very skilled.
But and again, Skywalker was a way,
way more powerful fighter.
when they cut away.
You notice that the golden droids
also refer to the waypoint
as the hinge, as in Stonehenge.
Like it's just another term
for a structure like this.
During their fight, you can see a soldier
trying to maneuver their fight
closer to the map so she can steal it
and prevent them from calculating
the rest of the hyperspace coordinates.
They jump back to Sabine versus Shehadeh
and show how
she's still trying to use the force,
but having a lot of trouble fighting her.
she is able to trick her
and get into the blaster shot,
just fooling her
into a sense of overconfidence.
But when she was actually reaching out
there,
she was trying
and failing to use the force.
Then they start cutting between
the different fights a little bit quicker.
Baylan continues to taunt Ahsoka
with the memory of the people injured.
Skywalker killed when he was Darth Vader,
in when she actually is able
to grab the map and deactivated
the thing that burns her hand.
Like the reason why it burns is because
of the Knight sister's green flame energy.
It's a type of force energy
that they literally call magic
and only Knight's sisters can wield.
Sabine arrives to help her out.
But Baylan strikes are so hard
that she almost flies off the cliff,
then eventually does push her off,
but she gets pulled into the world
between worlds.
I'll talk about that in a second, too,
because some people are like,
Wait a minute, how did that happen?
How did she make it into the world
between worlds end?
Predictably, like maybe a lot of you
actually called this early on.
But Sabine also fails to destroy the map
because Balon school basically
gets his hooks in her
and uses Ezra Bridger against
or the memory of Ezra Bridger against her
The whole idea is that
he's trying to use every trick in his bag
to twist her to his side and convince her
to eventually join the dark side.
I think that's his ultimate goal, is
he doesn't want to kill her.
He wants to turn another person
to the dark side.
That's also why I think that he's
trying to use the memory of Ahsoka
against her, like twist her against Ahsoka
that ultimately in the future,
if he needs to, he'll be able to use
Ahsoka as another ally to the dark side.
They also use this scene
to drop a bunch more exposition
in backstory to the original trilogy.
You know what happened to Sabine
after the events of Star Wars Rebels,
Balan confirms that her real family
house Wren Kleon Wren died
during the Great Purge of Mandalore
at the beginning of the original trilogy,
when he says it was because Ahsoka didn't
trust your master didn't trust you.
We'll probably learn more about that
in future episodes.
But I think the idea they're implying
is that Ahsoka prevented Sabine
from going to help her family on Mandalore
when that was going down
and they wound up dying when the Empire
bombed the planet in the slag.
but the whole idea
that he's
trying to get his hooks into her,
he's trying to say anything that he can
to twist her to the dark side
so that she'll give him the map.
True to his word, though,
he does spare her.
But like I said, I think he's trying
to twist her against Ahsoka.
Like, see,
I'm not going to go against my word.
Unlike your master.
the other detail here, too, is that
he talks about Ahsoka in past tense.
So I think that he believes that
Ahsoka is dead when she went off the cliff.
Shehadi also tries to kill Sabine,
but is stopped by Balan,
it sounds like they're just trying
to continue their whole rivalry
that they have into
the rest of the series.
Will they just continue
trying to kill each other?
Hera arrives
just in time to witness
the hyperspace ring,
even though they're going to try
and stop it by literally, just like.
Like parking a posting up
right in front of it
to prevent it from jumping in hyperspace.
It doesn't work
that's probably
just because the ship that they're
using to try and actually block
it aren't big enough.
maybe they had a couple of capital ships
to do that.
Or maybe if they were a little bit
closer to the actual ship.
they got into this whole concept
during the sequel trilogy,
like actually jumping into hyperspace
and not being able
to travel through something
without destroying both of you.
you notice Balan school destroys
the map was they have the full coordinates
to prevent anyone from the New Republic
from actually jumping between galaxies.
But the thing is, is that the space whales
actually know how to get between galaxies
just fine in.
Ezra Bridger is friend to the space
wells, it's
a lot of people wondering if they're going
to continue to use this new galaxy.
For more story in the Star Wars
universe in future series or other movies
or anything like that, They can totally do
that using the actual space whales.
there, a couple of Easter eggs
during some of these scenes,
like Carson Tebow's command lock as foils
and tack position is aligned directly
from a new hope they have Sabine.
They jump to the other galaxy
through hyperspace, which is predictable
because we knew that Thrawn
would eventually come back.
So they were always
going to probably be successful.
but the whole idea is that when she goes
the other galaxy, she'll have a chance
of seeing Ezra Bridger.
So they'll answer what happened to him
in this time gap.
there's so many questions
about what happened to Ezra.
I don't think that he went dark
or anything like that,
but I am expecting a couple of big twists.
when they jump in a hyperspace here,
it makes that oh, crap face.
Like, what are we going to do now?
Jason also says,
I have a bad feeling about this,
which is a line that many people in Star
Wars have uttered.
it's also a confirmation
that he's for sensitive like he's
sensing the coming danger in the force.
hoo. Yang is still on the planet.
So at some point,
Ahsoka is going to make it out of the world
between worlds in back to her ship.
But then they transition to a soldier
in the world between worlds.
And even though she looks kind of confused
when she wakes up in there,
she instantly recognizes where she is
because she remembers what it was to be
in the war between worlds
when Ezra saved her and pulled her
through time from the Sith Temple.
This place is ancient.
Like a world between worlds.
the world between Worlds
is sort of this space in the force
that exists out of time in space.
So you can
literally go anywhere in time in space
just through these different portals.
the the idea, though, is that the gateways
that Ezra Bridger was able
to use are very rare, like they appear all
over the galaxy, but they're super rare
and the gateways themselves
look a little bit like the star charts
inside the alien map here
from the ancient record of Empire.
so a lot of people wondering how did she
wind up in the world between worlds
because we didn't see an actual gateway,
like she didn't fall through a gateway.
it might have had something to do
with the force energy and the way
the actual map works, like it
probably opened a gateway to the world
between worlds.
But then they pay off one of the longest
running fan theories that we've had
since we heard that
Ahsoka was going to be a series.
Oh, my gosh, They're going to do an
antique and Skywalker cameo
and he's going to call her Snips,
just like the animated series.
This is where the fun begins.
I can't get much closer, Sky guy.
I knew you'd get here.
Sniffs eventually. Those
I didn't expect to see you since you
That was actually the first thing
she heard when she's facing away
and just hear his voice and it just says
Hello, snips in the background.
And she's like, Wait, what? Master?
She calls him Master first
until she turns around, in the smile
of recognition on her face
and calls him and again.
Then as it fades, the credits, the Darth
Vader theme music, much darker theme music
starts to play So the whole idea is
what's actually happening in this scene.
Like, why is Aniket appearing to her?
Is it just force goes
and it can appear in the force
to give her a bit of a pep
talk on her way to try and stop Thrawn in.
Are they going to tease her briefly
maybe for like a brief second,
thinking about trying to use the world
between worlds time travel
to save Anakin Skywalker
from becoming Darth Vader?
most of us fans would just be happy
if they spent all of episode five,
which is the two of them
talking to each other in a conversation
just an hour long conversation
inside the world between worlds,
Let me know in the comments.
What do you think
they're actually going to talk about?
And will they reference Luke Skywalker
or what happened during order 66 there?
Probably a couple of things
that they'll brush on, like a lot
of shared history in the previous movies
and The Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels.
but this was awesome.
I was so happy
that they finally paid this off
and they didn't wait till, like,
the very end of the series, like,
they did with Obi-Wan Kenobi
to have that big force ghost cameo scene.
Now, this makes you wonder
if they're doing this
halfway through the series,
What are they going to be doing
in the next couple of episodes?
Like how will things get even crazier?
the other interesting thing here, too,
like all those Sam Witwer theories
about him being a version of Morag,
is that he is credited
in the original Voices dialog scene.
So does that confirmed that he was meant
to be the voice of Morag?
Because his voice in the last episode
did sound a lot like Barak's voice.
Any sign of them?
Not for
discuss the concept of Starkiller
as an inquisitor.
Like Well, I know that, Dave, at one point
when you were doing Star Wars rebels
thought about
including him as an inquisitor.
Maybe it was one of those things
where he was just doing the James
Earl Jones thing
and he was just playing the actual voice
for the character,
and there's that a stunt actor
on set doing the physical performance,
kind of the
They do the Mandalorian character with
Pedro Pascal in the stunt actors on set.
there's so much to talk about
during this episode like so many theories
and questions born from what happened,
like what happened to Mark really
and what's going on with in
Can Skywalker in the world between worlds.
what will probably happen
though, is that we'll see
Thrawn in episode five,
like they'll pay that off.
But but a lot of the episode will be snips
in Skyguy
just hanging out talking about old times.
Don't worry, I will do a bunch of Anakin
Skywalker bonus videos this week.
There's so much to talk about.
post all your reactions
and your theories in the comments.
And are there any Easter eggs
or references
in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video
Just write them below in the comments.
Episode five Trailer video we'll post in
the next day or so to click here for that,
Update the link
as soon as I post that in, click here
for all my other Ahsoka videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!